en el vídeo pasado empezamos a platicar
acerca de los números complejos vimos
que eran vimos cómo podíamos graficar
los con un eje real y un eje imaginario
y también empezamos a platicar acerca de
sus operaciones de la suma de la resta y
de la multiplicación y nos quedamos en
medio de la división es decir estábamos
viendo o estábamos intentando determinar
cuánto era z1 en tres estados donde se
está uno y se está dos son complejos z
uno era a mi madre y y ceta 2 era c + d
y c + d
muy bien lo que te comenté en el vídeo
pasado es que vamos a utilizar esta
identidad que dice que a más b
por v es igual a cuadrada menos b
cuadrada ahora no tienes porqué
creérmela si no la has visto digo es muy
conocida pero si no la has visto o no te
acuerdas cómo probarla las cuentas o sea
que nada más multiplica los números y
simplifica y te va a quedar a cuadrada
menos b cuadrado bueno pero si tenemos
esta de aquí podemos aplicarla para
números complejos a qué me refiero vamos
a aplicarla para c + d y c de c
c - d vale entonces vamos a ver cuánto
nos queda es exactamente lo mismo verdad
y ahora ese nivel ahora es de y entonces
esto de aquí es igual a sea al cuadrado
c al cuadrado menos de i d y al cuadrado
muy bien esto de aquí podemos
simplificar lo que nos queda nos queda
sea al cuadrado y aquí utilizando leyes
de los exponentes nos quedan menos de
cuadrada y cuadrada y ve aquí tenemos
una y cuadrada que es un -1 menos uno
que con este menos hace que el segundo
término sea más y por lo tanto nos queda
igual hace cuadrada más de cuadrada
déjame hacer una pequeña observación que
está padre observa esto es lo que nos
dice es que si tenemos cualquier número
complejo y lo multiplicamos por éste que
se le parece mucho en el cual
simplemente la parte imaginaria tiene el
signo contrario entonces al final
obtenemos un número real
la suma de la parte real al cuadrado con
la parte imaginaria al cuadrado
bueno la dea al cuadrado va entonces
esto está muy bueno bueno pues esto pasa
porque estos dos números son especiales
entre sí y de hecho eso estos seres
especiales tiene un nombre déjame
ponerlo por acá o sea si tenemos si
tenemos un número complejo c c + d
vamos a llamarle digamos z entonces al
número complejo que obtenemos de cambiar
de signo su parte imaginaria c - de y le
llamamos su conjugado lo voy a poner
aquí conjugar
jugado
vale y el simbolito que se utiliza es
poner otra vez el número complejo pero
con una barrita arriba va entonces se
está conjugado es igual hace de otra
forma de escribirlo si no queremos
utilizar esta seta de acá es poner que
se dé y se ha conjugado es igual a cero
y si te das cuenta se me dé y conjugado
se menos de y conjugado es igual hace
igual que lo feo es igual hace más de y
muy bien entonces esto está padre porque
con estas ideas ahora sí vamos a poder
regresar a nuestro problema original y
encontrar cuál es esta división de acá
como le vamos a hacer bueno pues vamos a
multiplicar y dividir por el conjugado
del denominador déjame hacerlo para para
que se para que se vea a qué me refiero
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar por c - d i
y dividir en 13 m de aquí no estoy
haciendo nada verdad simplemente estoy
multiplicando por un 1 pero vamos a
realizar las operaciones para ver qué
nos queda entonces en el denominador en
el denominador pues es más de porsche m
pero justo acabamos de hacer eso aquí
abajito nos queda se cuadrada más de
cuadrada entonces le pongo ser cuadrada
más de cuadrado y en el numerador
tenemos un producto de ave y 11 m
de ahí entonces hay que hacer todos los
productos cruzados verdad
11a con menos de b con menos de 11 y
menos de y con bay no sé si lo dije bien
pero se ve la idea verdad entonces
multiplicamos 11 déjame agarrar otro
color aconsejé se hace luego con menos
de y es menos a d y luego es b y con sé
que es más
y finalmente es ve y con menos de y que
nos queda menos b de iu al cuadrado muy
bien déjame seguir de este lado entonces
ahora que vamos a hacer pues vamos a
cambiar el numerador a un número
complejo como hacemos eso pues juntamos
partes reales compartes reales e
imaginarias con imaginarias observa que
aquí hay una cuadrada este de aquí es
cuadrada que es un -1 entonces este
menos hace que aquí tenga signo más vale
bueno con eso en mente nos quedaría
igual a hace
hace más vd sí aquí es menos con menos
es más más y déjame poner primero el bc
porque es positivo bc - a d
d
y todo tenemos que dividir lo tenemos
que dividirlo en tres e cuadrada más de
cuadrada y puedes decir bueno eso no se
ve totalmente como un número complejo
porque estamos haciendo todavía una
división pero esta división ya es una
división entre un número real entonces
ya podemos distribuir esta división
hacia acá y hacia allá déjame hacerlo
vamos a ponerle esto de aquí es igual a
hace hace más ve de dividido en 13
cuadrada más de cuadrada vale y tenemos
que sumar veces menos a de menos a de
dividido en 13 cuadrada más de cuadrada
por iu y listo ahora si ya tenemos que
él
bueno el cociente o la división de estos
dos números complejos escrito como un
número complejo con su parte real y con
su parte imaginaria muy bien entonces
ahorita hacerlo es estas cosas con
variables bueno hacer estas cosas con
variables es es difícil y es un poco
abstracto así que vamos a hacer un
ejemplo con numeritos concretos para
entender cómo cómo se hace esto así ya
en un caso particular entonces déjame
déjame calcular cuánto es digamos 12 y 1
más 2 y dividido entre 2 + 3 y
todos más 3000 entonces la idea es
exactamente la misma que arriba vamos a
multiplicar y dividir por el conjugado
de 23 o sea 2 - 3
2 - 3
entonces esto es igual a aquí abajo
puedes hacer las operaciones con calma
nos va a quedar la diferencia de
cuadrados de la cual platicamos ahorita
lo voy a hacer yo rápido y después con
un poco de práctica tú también lo podrás
hacer así pero nos queda 2 al cuadrado 2
al cuadrado más 3 al cuadrado 3 al
cuadrado sale bueno vamos a la parte de
arriba en el numerador tenemos 1 por 2 3
21 por menos 3 y que es menos 3 y
tenemos 2 y por 24 y más 4 y 2 por menos
3 y que observa y por base y cuadrada
que es menos 1 entonces más por menos es
menos pero el menos que nos queda es más
hay que tener cuidado con no perderse
con los signos con tantas y si signos
negativos pero bueno aquí quedan más y
entonces es dos por 366 muy bien
entonces cuanto nos quedan dos más seis
es 8 4 y 3 10 y y tenemos que dividir
entre 4 2 al cuadrados 4 más 3 al
cuadrado que es 9 o sea entre 13 si
quieres que se vea así realmente con un
número complejo bajar realmente bueno
nos quedaría igual a 8 sobre 13 8 sobre
13 más 1 sobre 13 y muy bien entonces
pues ya está con esto ya ya realizamos
esta división y bueno como recomendación
si quieres aprender todavía más de los
números complejos y entenderlos un
poquito mejor te recomiendo así
agarrarte algunos números complejos
sencillitos hacer la suma resta
multiplicación división y sacarles
conjugado pero no sólo eso sino ver qué
sucede cuando haces eso cuando los
dibujas en el plano complejo con tu eje
imaginario y con tu vejez
eso te va a dar una mucho mejor
intuición de qué son los números
complejos bueno nos vemos hasta el
próximo vídeo